[Applaudissements]
tonalité culturel le bund allemand et
coureuses s'est pas séparé comme dans
l'temps de mon grand père
c'est la survie est
donc fort promet de doubler la
production bois en ontario s'il est
réélu
dans les prochains mois de m sauf un
implant critiqué par l'opposition et des
groupes environnementaux
mais qu'en pensent ils ontariens dont
les communautés dépendent de l'industrie
forestière
on a trop peu utilisé la conversation
puis on a créé une situation où les gens
se sentent comme si l'on était
complètement ignorés on s'est rendu à
rust dans la forêt boréale pour sonder
les électeurs
il
ballon s'en va nos opérations
forestières on est vraiment la fin de la
saison on veut vraiment être capable de
sortir le bois en faisant le moins de
dommages possibles
en ontario 0,2 pour cent de la
superficie de la forêt et récoltés
annuellement chaque arbre coupé doit
être planté mais depuis des années
l'industrie n'exploite que la moitié des
volumes approuvé par la province
d'oxford de doubler la récolte en
augmentant la construction résidentielle
et réduire la dépendance au marché
américain
comme en amour avec sa machine
mois s'est mise pour le nez qui je suis
travailleur autonome donc il ya pas seul
job dans l'industrie du beau d'annoncer
ce qui coûte beaucoup
l'économie n'ont donc c'est certain que
ses promoteurs savoir que l'implication
de vouloir grosse et la production c'est
surtout ses bienfaits
[Musique]
c'est sarah a pas le cas et puis je suis
forman pour le columbo cac on coupe on a
fait d'eux les com/ca/fra feux de forêt
ça c'est le plus naturellement possible
à savoir si beaucoup d sais c'est pas
des corps il s'est vraiment des zigzags
est ce que c'est beau à voir après une
coupe frêche non c'est pas quelque chose
qui va très bien pour les yeux mais est
ce que c'est bon pour la forêt oui on
arrache les feux de forêt on y cite avec
les maladies à dinan fort et mon nom
c'est guettant berjon je suis conseiller
de la ville de russes le chemin de la
première nation de candy s'inscrit donc
food a exhorté l'industrie forestière de
la loi sur les espèces en voie de
disparition
la loi identifié de vastes territoires
protégés pour le caribou à rust un sujet
sensible des troupeaux fréquentent les
extrémités de la forêt ici a reçu
c'était pour se saouler peu sur le
terrain ça voulait dire qu'on perdait à
chaque année un tiers des caisses qu'on
pouvait couper donc à long terme des
trois moulins ici qui veut dire que un
des trous envoyé 25 m'enfermer serre est
venu parler aux jeunes cantini slate
puis les autres personnes de la région
on avait pu leur montrer où ce qui est
testé deux petits troupeaux l'appui
comment travailler ensemble faire ce que
existe encore puis sans dire qui ont
cours depuis cette pointe
d'oxford a aussi éliminé un mécanisme
utilisé par les citoyens pour retarder
des coupes forestières controversée du
même souffle des travailleurs comme
mitch se retrouver sans revenu pendant
des mois
elle se souvient des décisions qui sont
prises
que je sais que c'est bien pour réseau
dans le sud mais pas nécessairement pour
le nom de cet emploi thème démographique
on a peur on a pas la population toronto
mais
ici on travaille plus on ne sort pas des
matières premières ayant vu ou pas grand
chose en échange de temps
nous
[Musique]
en
plus des récoltes veut dire plus de
chemins forestiers en ontario des
milliers de kilomètres sont construits
chaque année c'est la principale cause
de déforestation dans le nord et c'est
sans compter les résidus forestiers qui
pourrissent en bordure des chemins
mais la régénération des chemins et
complexes
en est en consultation publique
présentement parce qu'on aimerait miser
sur aussi régénéré ces secteurs là du
chemin puis pour le réseau d'eau complet
on a beaucoup de consultations à faire
avec la communauté autochtone parce que
c'est un chemin qui est activement
utilisée pour l'attraper la chasse
traditionnelle mon nom c'est dommage la
route je suis directrice générale pour
la compagnie d'aménagement forrester
dans le sport reste j'ai un marché pour
nom pour les branches non pour les
épines mais j'ai seulement un marché
pour le premier sas pied mais ce voile
humler si j'étais capable de travailler
avec afin de stimuler une accessibilité
pour les marchés ou développer un marché
pour je pourrais presque doubler mon
voyons pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
maximisent pas l'utilisation de chaque
arbre chaque et chaque hectare de forêt
qui a déjà été exploité une tactique
pourquoi est ce que j'utilise du gaz
naturel quand je peux chaufferie au bois
c'est toute une dynamique où on peut
regarder aa + régionalisés
notre économie en ontario quelques
centrales génèrent déjà de l'électricité
avec des résidus forestiers la biomasse
est une source d'énergie renouvelable
puisque le dioxyde de carbone rejeté
lors de la combustion est absorbé par
les végétaux à son arrivée au pouvoir le
gouvernement faudra songer à fermer la
centrale de rust pour sauver de l'argent
mais a récemment changé du des actions
consomment encore plus debout mais ils
vont en plus de sous produits il voit
plus de biomasse
je pense qu'on va devoir jouer un rôle
important dans cette vision est là parce
qu'on a quand même plusieurs comme usine
comme la nôtre puis qui existe des
jaunards lors de l'ontario je pense
qu'on serait capable de supporter
beaucoup de ce match et l'eau
c'est pas comme des grosses minières ou
ce que c'est des gens d'ailleurs qu'ils
s'en foutent un peu ils prennent tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pis en art les
propriétaires camp dial à l'aréna avec
leur enfer qui jouent au hockey il voit
les travailleurs qui voit la communauté
fait qu'il ya un sens de communauté on
veut que ça soit bien gérer tout ce
passe bien reste à voir si les cadeaux
de d'oxford à l'industrie forestière se
traduiront en votes en 2018 le
néo-démocrate guy bourgoin a été élu
avec 52 % des voix dans musique egobook
baie james où 90% des électeurs sont
francophones ou autochtone moi je
demanderais au grand maman qui va entrer
en plus d'être à l'écouté des gens sinon
c'est du beau monde qui se présentent
mais il reste que son époux dans de bons
sièges dont on est en train de se battre
pour garder notre économie en place veut
doubler la production forestière d'ici
2030 est ce que vous êtes d'accord et
oui
d'autant qu'on protège nos forêts
et qu'on nous aide les compagnies à
avoir plus de travail en russie ont été
élevés dans le métier de la foresterie
montgermont pacé un camionneur
et devinez le bois toute sa vie donc oui
c'est la survie de notre petit fils
d'horus absolument l'industrie
forestière c'est le backbone du nord
comme les mines mais les mines c'est par
une nouvelle disent que l'industrie
forestière surnombre a besoin ça va
durer éternellement
arrêtez d'avoir un focus sur ben et
n'oubliez pas les communautés rurales du
nord qui n'ont pas les votes ne les voit
ni le pôle un politique pour pouvoir
avoir cette influence la puis prenez
fierté dans le travail qu'on ait fait
que pour nous pour vous et pour
l'ontario parce qu'on a de quoi être
fier
[Musique]